hello everyone cross-generational bells
are always interesting I've already done
a video on Michael Dallas game against
Garry Kasparov and I covered the game
were Michael Todd played against
Vishwanathan Anand and here we also have
a rare treat thirteen or fourteen year
old magnus carlsen is playing against
the legendary Viktor Korchnoi the game
was played in 2004 it was a tournament
called smart fish chess masters I was
played in Norway and ten players
participated in this tournament I will
tell you something about the results and
the standings after I showed you the
game Viktor here opens the game with c4
the English opening we have Knight to f6
Knight to c3 and c5 sewed the
symmetrical variation of the English g3e
six and Knight to f3 Knight to c6 Bishop
to g2 and the d5 by Carlsen C captures a
captures and d4 Bishop to e7 by Carson
and the Bishop to e3 and this looks like
a weird move why would you play
something like this to block your own e
to pawn but the victor actually has a
pretty good idea c-4 by Carson and this
seems like a reasonable response you
wanna lock this pawn on d4 did not allow
Viktor to capture on c5 and now
definitely this bishop does look
suspicious on e3 but coronet plays
Knight to e5 and now you see that this
night is very strong on e5 even though
you know it's always it's always hard to
get rid of a knight a white knight on e5
but now there's really no way to get rid
of it even if you tried something like
moving the f6 Knight and maybe pushing
f6 that would only ruin your King's pawn
structure but capturing is definitely
not recommended if you capture them
after D captures you can't go to these
seven you lose the d5 pawn and if you
try something like Knight to g4 to make
me mess up White's pawn structure then
this Bishop can come to d4 and now it's
pretty good for example Bishop to e6 and
now h3 the knight has only one square to
go h6 and for example G for white is
already to push f4 f5 it's a very
pleasant position for
white so after this Knight to e5 Carson
castles Victor also castles and here
Bishop to e6 was played and this was a
small inaccuracy that allowed Victor a
very nice tactic
better yet was either developing the
rook may be pushing h6 but if you want
to develop the bishop may be a better
square would have been f5 but okay
Carson goes for Bishop to d6 and here he
allows the Victor this Knight captures
on c4 move you pretty much have to
capture the night otherwise you're down
upon Saudi captures on c4 and now d5 by
Victor attacking the knight and the
bishop here Carlson captures knife
captures on d5 who have night captors on
d5 and now Bishop to f6 attacking the B
to pawn and the victor simply plays
Queen to d2 defending the B to pawn
bishop to d4 by Carlson and Awards the
idea behind Bishop to d4 well if you
capture it then Carson can capture on d5
the Queen is no longer attacking the d5
square so after Bishop to d4 Knight to
f4 by Korchnoi Bishop captures on e3
Queen captures on d3 and rook to e8 rook
F to D 1 attacking the Queen Queen moves
to f6 and now again call Carson is
attacking the B to pawn and here course
no gives up the Bishop Bishop captures
and c6 b captures on c6 and Queen to d4
offering a trade of Queens Queen
captures rook captures and Bishop to d5
and if you look at this position now
it's a definitely a better position for
white Carson has these weird CC pawns
but can coroner actually do something
about it it's hard to say this e to
point is attacked by the rook okay for
now it's protected by the night but if
Knight ever wants to capture it he will
have to move the knight so rook a to d1
court my first doubles up on the d file
and here Carlson has to find he has to
find some kind of a plan either start
improving the position of his own King
or something start expanding on the on
the Queen side but here Carson actually
see three with the idea that if B
characters and see three he will capture
with the bishop a native but this
actually isn't bad for white question I
can simply capture and see three and
after Bishop captures rook to a 1 and
now fortunately and now cousin is the
one that has two isolated pawns and it's
hard to say if he will be able to defend
them against coronaries rooks but after
this CC three move corner plate Knight
captures on d5 immediately and this wins
upon by by force seek after Sun d5 and B
captures on c3 now cousin does grab back
to e2 pawn rook captures on e - but now
rook captures on d5 and Carson doesn't
have time to capture on a2 because rook
to d8 will lead checkmate after rook
captures and the other rook captures so
g6 cousin has to make some room reading
room for the king and rook F 5 - d - now
protecting the a to pawn and also
offering a trade of rooks other than
this move probably a 4 is also valid
consideration but it's hard to say which
move is better is the white better here
well there are 4 rooks on the board or
is white better if he trades off a pair
of Brooks cautionary decides the trade
of one pair of rooks so rook captures
rook captures and you know if anyone in
in the world was famous for his endgame
skilled and it was a Viktor Korchnoi
and I don't think he had any doubts that
he would win this against a young Magnus
Carlsen
so rook the c8 Mikaelson rook to c2
protecting the past pawn and now look to
see for not allowing Courtley to push
this passed pawn any further so King to
f1 now both players will start improving
the position of their kings came to f8
painted e 2 came to e7 came to d3 and
rook to a 4 and here Rob to d2 was
played it's very hard for Korchnoi to
actually improve his position this rock
is coming off the 4th rank this rook has
to keep protecting the a2 upon the King
can't go further so sorry probably a
better idea than rope to the
will maybe be too pushy for and then cut
off the rooks the rook and then maybe
grab more space by the King but there's
no rush in doing this first portion of
place erupted e2 King to e6 and now c4
rook to a3 check King goes further up
the board King to e4 and h5 here we have
F 4 F 6 and rook to e2 rock - a for King
to D for defending the pawn king to d6
and rook to f2 now here Kirchner would
very much enjoy pushing f5 either to
capture on g6 or if Carlsen captures
then he will break up this pawn
structure and create two more isolated
pawns this would be excellent for white
so Carlson has to defend this he plays
rook to a5 and kink the c3 kink the c5
now keep the b3 not allowing rook check
the King on a3 Rock to a6 and in this
position cautionary played rook to d2
and Carlsen lost the game on time so
fortunately won this game and I read
somewhere that at one point in the game
cousin left the board and he forgot to
hit the clock so his time was running
while it was actually still his his move
but he didn't know that I couldn't
confirm this so if anyone who knows if
this is true or has some article that
would prove this please do share in the
comments I will add it in the
description but if not I mean even if
that was the case that's not Victor's
fault you know you have to you have to
hit the clock that's otherwise you're
gonna run out of time and lose so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
as you all know Viktor Korchnoi died
last year in June in 2016 at the age of
85 and I think in his entire career he
defeated nine world champions and
Coulson wasn't a world champion at the
time this game was played but you know
he managed to take down one more future
world champion so yeah I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank our own
waffle art Kevin Keith and Lucas
Robinson for contribution to my
Lucas contributed the amounted morphe
declined after winning the first
American chess congress so thank a lot a
very thoughtful of you
and I I will say something about the
results understandings this was actually
one of Carlson's worst tournaments he
ever played out of ten players he won
shared last place but in the end he was
last in this tournament Antoinetta
stefanova was ninth the tournament was
won by alexei Scheer of second was Peter
high Nielsen cousins Tudor and third
place was Luke McShane so yeah not not
the best tournament for Carlson but in a
year from this tournament he will be
able to defeat anyone he ever faces so
it's not it's not that big of a deal so
ya think you'll think all for watching
and I would like to thank you for
following my twitch channel after
yesterday's announcement I already
received like six hundred and fifty
follows so that's like huge thank you
very much and thank all for watching
this video and I will see you soon